well thank you so much for doing this
really appreciate it thank you okay so
when I when I think about chess and what
I've always heard about chess is that
it's about seeing the next move and
seeing the move after the move and
forgive like the dumb question but just
sort of what does it look like in your
brain when you're playing a game are you
seeing all the possibilities and I mean
just describe it what what is what do
you see when you look when a computer
looks at a position it will consider all
the possibilities you will see all the
different possibilities and it will
calculate them many many moves ahead for
me it's more about seeing the right
possibilities finding the right ideas
and evaluating them correctly and if I
need to I will be able to calculate the
most many many moves ahead but it's
really more about finding finding the
right ones and then the board is always
pictured in my head there's an image of
of the board moving moving the pieces
around so you you see your move
happening and the move happening and
then the next one and you can kind of
feel it feel it out what is that what is
that feeling like when it's like you're
you're processing what you want to do
and then it's like a physical sensation
when you sort of know the move you want
to make what does it feel like I think
it's partly subconscious because
sometimes there will be a
decision-making process and in my mind
and then suddenly I make a move and I
really don't know why I did that I I
really I really cannot sometimes sense
the moment when I decide on that
particular move and at some point I just
make it and do you feel when you made
the wrong moves there asked like how
does that feel like how often how long
does it usually take before you feel
like you made the wrong one well the
strange thing is that usually when I
make a bad move I see immediately why
that is a bad move and that happens too
many strong players
it's it's really hard to say maybe it's
because it's a little bit easier to see
the move that can happen when it act
when it's actually on the board then
just in your head but it's it's a
fascinating problem so you know there
are people who love the opening game the
middle game and late game you you the
middle game is your favorite part at
least that's what I've heard in the past
is that the case and and why what's the
what's that why is that part I think
well there are different parts parts of
the game there is the opening where a
lot depends on analysis at home with
computers and the computer is an
incredibly powerful tool in chess and
it's a lever leveler of the playing
field so for me I feel that I have
greater ability than than the others so
I try to analyze try to choose opening
openings that minimize the effect of of
computer analysis and then often in the
end games if there are seven pieces are
left
everything's been worked out by the
computer so if there are seven pieces or
less total by total for each side then
it's it's all worked out and you can
just go on to to a website check out
what's what's the right move in any
position so between that you have the
middle game and there it comes down to
pure chess ability and that's why that's
my favorite there are seven pieces left
it's like oh this is already written I
know what's gonna happen well it can be
very difficult some some positions like
if you have a rook against rook and
Knight against two knights the computer
might show you that white can win in two
hundred and seventy five moves with
correct play
and that is really too difficult for me
or any other human I've tried to play
through the moose try to understand them
but it's really hard to see the
difference between the position that you
have now and that you have 50 moves
later on and then 50 moves after that
it's again not much of a difference so
that that is beyond my comprehension but
but but most of the time yeah with seven
pieces or less the evaluation is known
and it's possible to figure it out why
over the summer I actually I wrote a
book and and I had to write a lot of
words in a short period of time and I
found that you know I started to realize
that my my my body was like a machine
and I needed to get a certain amount of
sleep I I know I couldn't have a certain
amount of drinking you know I needed to
sort of be able to like tune my body in
a way to like write better and I could
get to a better word count chess is
chess is like a physical activity you're
at a board it's a two-hour match how do
you train yourself as like an athlete to
to be ready for for a chess match well I
think that in general I think being in
being a bit tired or drunk or whatever
it's it shouldn't be so bad for for
writing a book because I think when your
brain is not when when you when you're
not properly rested you can be as
creative or more creative than when
you're properly rested the problem is
that is that you're the rate of errors
goes up quite quite a bit right and
that's what what I felt when once I
played the world blitz championship and
I had I had a bug so I was up all night
I couldn't couldn't sleep at all
throwing up feeling terribly and that
and and that day I played some some of
the most
creative chess I've ever played and I
also made the worst blunders however
I've ever done so I think for playing
top level chassis it is important though
to to feel physically fit because then
you'll be better concentrated and you
will not make simple mistakes and it
doesn't matter how many good moves you
make as long as you make one really bad
one
and what do you do to get into that
frame of mind where you are eliminating
mistakes as best as possible in a
physical sense well it's it's it's
always a balance because I want to have
a lot of energy but I also want to be
calm so I don't know it's it's it's it's
hard I'm still trying to find that
balance but obviously to sleep to sleep
well to eat well during tournaments
that's that's a thing you you must do do
you know I understand you're something
of a sports fan which which you know
basketball soccer do you have any sort
of do you see any sort of parallels
between how are those athletes to go
about their their lives work and you go
about yours yeah I think especially
during big events it's it's very similar
you you have your own little bubble that
you bet you live in and everything is
about eating sleeping and preparing for
for the next game and getting some some
rest you know so I think it's what I do
in training and tournaments it's it's
very similar to to what athletes do so
you know the story out there is that
your style has evolved over the years
from something of more of like a grinder
style to more creative in recent years
is that an accurate narrative that
people have sort of put out there and
just sort of tell me the story of for
you how your style has evolved over over
the years well ever since I was little
I've always liked to
to read about chess - to play through
games of different styles but and to be
inspired by them but I guess when I was
younger as most people are I was more of
an attacking player after all
the game is about checkmating the king
and as a less experienced player you
want to reach that goal as quickly as
possible but as you face better
opposition though it becomes more
difficult they have better defensive
techniques and that's why after a while
I realized that I needed to to play the
end games better to be a bit more
restrained perhaps not you know burn the
bridges all the time and then recently
again I've tried to to be a bit more
creative because you cannot always win
games by superior technique sometimes
you need to create something something
unique to to baffle your opponents so
you know would it be possible for you
you know you've catalogued all these
games and other people have played you
remember your own games I mean are you
able to describe the most exciting you
know series of moves that you've made in
your career that the ones that sort of
like you know we're for you personally
maybe it's not even a championship and
it's in an early age where you sort of
had a breakthrough or
yeah I had a big win or just or even in
the middle game sort of set yourself up
for a win well I think the single most
important tournament win for me was the
Norwegian Championship under eleven in
2000 that was that was a big deal for me
as for games I don't know for one of
what used to be perhaps my favorite game
was my game with then
champion Arnon from 2010 because in that
game I felt like I created something out
of nothing and it gave me a great deal
of creative satisfaction even though I
didn't actually win the game but I guess
it's it's always a bit different what I
appreciate in my own games and other
people games from what most people
appreciate because most people want to
see making attacks on the what do you
appreciate I appreciate really the
creating something unique and that can
be and some kind of attack but just an
idea something I haven't seen before
that is what fascinates me you once said
that computers have made the game less
dogmatic what did you mean by that it
means that moves that look bad or an
aesthetic hour they are considered by
the top players while well previously
people will kind of shy away from those
kind of ugly moves but now the thing is
that because of the computers because of
the computers birth calculation people
are more more and more starting to see
every position as a they have to see
them concretely because you cannot rely
on on what has been taught in books like
this is good this is bad there are
always exceptions and every situation is
different and even if something looks
looks bad it doesn't look right you
calculated it you calculate it it works
and there you go it's fascinating that a
computer sort of helps foster creativity
even though it's the thing that's
right I mean it's sort of forcing into
creativity in a sense yeah it's it's
just forcing us to to look look a bit
further to to look away from what the
books used to teach us it's forcing us
to break the rules is there a moment is
actually is you know is that why play
Magnus you're your app the the sense of
this I mean how does that sense of like
the computer can help people sort of be
more creative how does that work into
this this product that you're sort of
you're helping usher into the world and
why is this important to you you don't
have to be doing this kind of thing you
can just play chess and maybe famous all
right for me it's interesting to to see
the play of play Magnus at different
ages because sometimes it is modeled
after my playing style and strength but
all those different ages and then I I
played I tested myself against nine was
twelve at some point Adam and I it was
kind of strange because I thought this
this is not right I mean minus twelve is
only going for four king attacks and
he's not he has no technique there's
it's all times it's it's not right
that's not how I played at that age and
then I decided to play through quite a
bit of my games from that age and I
realized it was what was right but yeah
I think I think it's it's it's a great
tool and and it's something for people
to to strive after so it's it's
interesting for people to play against
the computer you beat the computer at
one level then you advance to the next
but if you're actually playing a human
opponent it's much more interesting you
know to
to advance to the next next age and once
you get to to a certain age it's it's
it's really good I mean if you beat -
for instance at ten years old you've
you've done really really well because
not a lot of people are able to do not a
lot of people were able to beat that do
you like this do you like being a world
champion and this famous and like you're
in photoshoots with models and things
like that
is it is it what you wanted out of this
or you know what what are you you're 24
years old and you're the best what do
you do well I like being world champion
that's for sure so what about world
famous world champion well famous really
not not being a goal for me so I'm very
happy and very privileged that I can
earn a good living from from playing
chess and I want to bring the happy
message of chess to the world because
whenever wherever I travel I see a lot
of kids playing chess both a chess clubs
and at schools and it brings them so
much joy and that is why I want more
people to do it to play the game but for
me personally fame and all that comes
with it is it's not a go well thank you
so much for doing this I really
appreciate it a lot of fun